[Music]
[Applause]
we talked about the dolphin situation it
certainly feels like they're guilty of a
lot here I don't know if they really
felt the pain they lost a draft pick
first round draft pick coming up lost
another draft pick the owner is not
allowed to be around the team for a
couple of months and uh they're fined
1.5 million dollars Louis Riddick joins
us on behalf of the mothership ESPN
front office Insider Louis when you look
at tampering and you look at tanking
you're trying to better your team
but which one is more egregious to you
well I think tanking for sure because of
the far-reaching implications that
intentionally trying to lose games Dan I
mean that that has and that is I mean
just just look at
it all right just look at the kind of
penalty that they hit Calvin Ridley with
when compromising the Integrity of the
game obviously comes into question when
you're talking about betting on football
games and how that can have far-reaching
you know ramifications
when you're talking about
not emphasizing winning games
or trying to lose for whatever reason it
is in this case to try and better your
draft position
I mean understand that's obviously
compromising the Integrity of the game
because the game is not even not being
played true to the way it needs to be
played which is to win
now so I would think that that is much
worse
than tampering which is something that
we know
happens okay we all know that people
talk to people who are under contract
and strike deals long before it's
probably it's permissible for you to
strike deals you know the good old you
know
the good old secret meetings whereas you
you wind up making some some
transactions that aren't official until
they become official until they're
allowed to be become official but this
feels like select selective punishment
for tampering if it goes on all the time
it's everybody knows there's a speed
limit that doesn't mean we adhere to the
speed limit but then you get pulled over
and there are other cars that are going
just as fast well I think there's some
time I think sometimes that that is what
the NFL gets criticized for as far as
you know as far as how they hand out
punishment that sometimes it does feel
selective and subjective and not fair
and you know on the level across the
board
now I will say that the commissioner
wrote in his you know in his statement
there that this was egregious tampering
of a level that he has never seen before
in terms of tampering with a quarterback
and a head coach who are both under
contract and Untouchable and doing it
for the period of time that they did it
yeah in the Brazen way in which they did
it and that is I mean look I mean when
you start using those kind of words
just like when they use those kind of
words you know when judge Robinson used
that kind of word to describe the DeSean
Watson case when she's talking about
egregious and predatory there's certain
words Adam you know I mean I'm not
telling you something you don't know
when those kind of things are said
that makes you perk up a little bit and
go well even for these guys who kind of
know how it kind of goes yeah as far as
you know the commissioner knows what
we're talking about here as far as Tim
he knows what's going on but when he
uses that word like God I mean like he's
almost saying like I can't I mean what
am I supposed to do when I look at this
I'm like damn but do you think that Sean
Payton would have quit the Saints
yeah like he knew that he was getting
the Dolphin's job
right
do you think that he quit the Saints
knowing he was going to get the Dolphins
job and then it didn't happen and then
he ended up going into broadcasting I
don't know I I really don't
um
but if you look at the breadcrumbs here
Brady you know retires from the
Buccaneers and then all of a sudden
Dolphins rumors meeting on the yacht
Brian Flores says I don't want to be
involved Sean Payton's Avail like
there's a whole lot going on here yeah I
I don't know you know as far as how you
know when Sean
made the decisions that he made as far
as quitting the Saints and then moving
on into broadcasting or how that came
about what I do know though is one of
the names that you just brought up there
in that whole scenario that being Brian
Flores just think about for me
think about how this man has been being
undermined
right from the outset while he's the
head coach of you know going back to the
2019 season
I mean where he is sitting there knowing
that there are people who are
emphasizing
draft position over winning football
games and then
knowing that obviously you know there's
people who are actively trying to
replace him while he's being hired to do
his job and then the implications that
that has for minority coaches and I'm
like this this is so there's there's so
many different layers to it
and what it means and how it affects
others when you and then you know and it
all falls under that compromising the
Integrity of the game umbrella all of it
yeah so I don't think I think when you
factor in all of that the effect that it
had on Brian Flores the effect you know
that
you know the perception that it
obviously creates amongst the fans I
mean the commissioner had no other
choice he had another choice just from
the tampering aspect he had no other
choice but who jokes about who jokes
about tanking who nobody like
I'm just kidding yeah no kidding there's
a little there's a little truth in every
bit of kidding exactly exactly you're
right that is the kind of thing that I
would assume you have a reasonable
amount of awareness
to the fact that you can't joke and kid
about that kind of thing no you can't
say it and then just go oh I'm just
messing up oh don't take me yeah you're
absolutely right and I think everyone
who has any kind of Common Sense and has
a little bit of
awareness knows that you're right with
every joke there is a little bit of
truth to it and in this case it's
something that
you it just can't be tolerated not if
you want to be
taken as credible in terms of holding
everyone accountable and see look that's
a whole other subject right I mean we're
talking about the whole
accountability issue when it comes to
the NFL making sure that they're holding
everyone to the very highest standard
and people have a big problem I think
that's more or less at the Crux of
everyone right now's anger and
disappointment is the level of
accountability being fair and Equitable
across all parties Players management
coaches owners and quite honestly what
the NFL has said themselves we need to
hold management and ownership to higher
standards than to than to which we even
hold the players and many people are
feeling as though that's not the case
well you look at Deshawn Watson look do
I think he got off uh you know easier he
should have sat down for a season in my
opinion sure but it's based on precedent
here right the thing with owners is we
don't necessarily have that much
precedent here that I can go Daniel
Snyder Stephen Ross or Jerry Jones or
Robert Kraft they're not held to a
higher standard right because if if I'm
I don't know if the commissioner is this
angry at Deshawn Watson's ruling as he
was with what Stephen Ross and the
Dolphins are guilty up here like if I
look at his language there he is p.o'd
because you're looking at the Integrity
of the game the bottom line is is
gambling you've got to trust the shield
like this to me is more egregious yes
DeSean Watson predatory uh creep and
should sit down and get therapy and
those kind of things yeah but these
These are owners here yeah this is you
know the the
the interesting well I guess you should
say well the the weird dynamic here
though is he works for them
yes and so you know so therefore he's
like saying look I know I work for you
but I I need to set up some rules and
guidelines by which if you step over the
line here I can then come at you and hit
you with and I need to make sure that it
is swifted into severe and everyone
understands that these are the rules
that are non-negotiable and you cannot
do these things and if I find that
you've done these things
this is the amount of money you're going
to get hit with this is the amount of
suspension you're gonna get and see that
that's kind of like that's kind of like
what judge Robertson said like there is
no system in place where the NFL
basically has that all set so everyone
understands what the rules are it's kind
of like made up as you go yeah it's very
reactionary instead of Forward Thinking
which is exactly what she said this is a
league that may be forward facing but
it's not very much so forward thinking
and that's what gets people that's what
gets them into trouble you know what I
shouldn't we shouldn't put this on her
it shouldn't be on her to change the
NFL's ways of doing things and how they
punish somebody it should be on the NFL
does the does the commissioner appeal
this does the NFL appeal this and go
after for more with DeShawn they got 24
hour less than 24 hours here as much as
they don't may not want to because they
would like to have this new system take
hold
the fact of the matter is just as far as
having a third party decide these kind
of uh punishments I don't think they
have any other choice the the reaction
has been just too it's been too
emotional it's been too explosive and I
think they know in their heart of hearts
and in their soul that but this is just
it's just not enough given what she said
that the NFL did prove
in terms of presenting the evidence to
her she's basically she agreed with him
no as far as what they what they
presented to her but she's just saying
but
I'm not going to do something that you
wouldn't even do or what you haven't
done in the past in terms of handing
down punishment I'm just going to follow
the guidelines that you have done in the
past so it's your fault that I'm not
gonna hit him even harder although I
agree with you
which has got to be like wow
it should make you meaning the NFL sit
back and think well maybe we need to
reevaluate your the personal conduct
policy and how punishment is handed out
and we need to make it a little bit more
concrete a little bit more you know
so the players and the owners know
exactly what they're dealing with if
they are if they step over the line
what's what exactly is coming
because right now what she basically
told them is
you don't really have a system in place
great to talk to you as always Lewis
thank you for your insights absolutely
thanks Louis Riddick former NFL player
ESPN front office Insider